yesterday the markets tanked I think
lost around 1200 1200 points something
like that yeah absolutely tagged and
Biden was given a speech as the markets
were tanking and Fox News jumped in and
interrupted the president for years so
many of us have been trying to fix this
problem
but for Years big Pharma blocked
Medicare from negotiating lower drug
practices prices
all right I do not want to be a party
crasher but we interrupt this
celebration for a hard cold dose of
reality stocks tanking because inflation
is accelerating the very inflation that
the President says he's made great
progress addressing heralding his
inflation reduction act as the Boon for
the economy that we didn't see in a key
number out earlier today all right so
you see how insane this is they are
throwing a party at the White House for
the inflation reduction act as the
market is tanking the numbers are going
down not good as he is telling you what
we did by printing the money and putting
more money out there and
his dysregulated emotions and all of
that stuff just I mean it's just perfect
juxtaposition it's absolutely perfect
we've got some some data on inflation
actually this is from the New York Post
yesterday U.S inflation Rose by a higher
than expected 8.3 percent in August
despite falling gasoline prices adding
pressure on the Federal Reserve as it
decides whether to impose another
super-sized interest rate hike the
August reading of the labor Department's
Consumer Price Index a closely watched
watched measure of the cost of good and
services Rose 0.1 percent compared to
July surprising economists who had
expected a slight month over month
decline now first off you know it's even
funny the way the New York Post which is
pretty good even the way they framed
that I mean yes gas prices have gone
down a little bit but that's only
because they went up a crazy amount so
that's what they always do right it's
like boy you've destroyed everything and
then things got a little bit better oh
my God don't you see things got a little
bit better it's just absolutely
spectacular but anyway the point is
the economy is not in great shape we all
know it and I would prefer that it would
be what a refreshing day it would be to
come in here if we woke up tomorrow if I
woke up tomorrow morning and I'm doing
at 7 15 a.m and I'm going back and forth
on my text with Phoenix and we're trying
to put the show together and he's like
Dave you're not going to believe it I
was up a half hour earlier than you and
Biden fixed the whole thing it would be
refreshing I wouldn't even know what to
do with myself it would be quite lovely
but it ain't going to happen
unfortunately